[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu l'observation il y
en a t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance et
retransmises en direction Public Sénat
et sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns des autres
et au respect du temps de parole je
donne la parole immédiatement à notre
collègue Olivier sigotique pour le
groupe de l'Union sportive
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs mes les ministres madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues la
pire des choses serait de penser que
nous Européens devrions être suivis sur
le sujet de Taïwan et nous adapter au
rythme américain et à une surréaction
chinoise ces propos du président de la
République suite à sa visite d'État en
Chine ont suscité intolé international à
la veille de manœuvre chinoise sans
précédent
cette polyphonie ne peut que nous
affaiblir madame la Première ministre ma
question est donc double la France
va-t-elle lever tout ambiguïté sur sa
position vis-à-vis de Taïwan et comment
l'exécutif entend-il concrètement faire
avancer l'idée d'autonomie européenne
sans remettre en cause le portable le
partenariat privilégié que nous avons
avec notre allié américain
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur Véran monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Olivier
sigolotti je vous prie d'avoir d'excuser
Madame Catherine Colonna qui est au côté
du président de la République dans le
cadre de sa visite d'État au Pays-Bas la
position de la France s'agissant de la
situation en Asie et constante premier
point l'Union européenne doit défendre
ses propres intérêts c'est légitime et
ne viendrait à l'idée de personnes de le
contester le président de la République
a toujours dit nous ne sommes pas à
décuis distance de Washington et de
Pékin nous partageons des valeurs la
relation avec Pékin s'inscrit dans un
cadre européen très clair depuis 2019
partenariat concurrence économique
rivalité systémique nous voulons éviter
une logique de confrontation bloque à
bloc sur Taïwan nous sommes opposés à
toute modifications unilatérale du statu
quo a forcé Aurélie par la force c'est
une position claire et constante de la
France dans le cadre de notre d'une
seule Chine nous avons d'importantes
coopérations avec Taïwan dans de
nombreux domaines et nous nous y tenons
face au défi rencontrer dans cette
région les Européens doivent aussi
défendre leurs intérêts économiques de
manière indépendante ils l'ont fait en
développant des instruments de défense
commerciale précisément à l'initiative
de la France c'est aussi le sens du
dérisking qui vise à diversifier nos
sources d'approvisionnement au cours de
son déplacement le président de la
République a dit très clairement les
choses au président chies sur tous les
sujets dans le cadre d'un dialogue
exigeant et franc assez éloigné des
polémiques je vous remercie
monsieur gigoletti
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
éléments mais de l'Ukraine à Taïwan nos
alliés ne peuvent que s'interroger sur
la stratégie française à l'international
j'entends que le Président de la
République veuille faire de la
souveraineté européenne une priorité
erreur d'analyses ou faute tactique
peut-être ces propos sont à son retour
de Chine et restent pour autant un
magnifique cadeau diplomatique fait au
Président si Jean Ping merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente Eliane assassy pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole merci
monsieur que le président ma question
sera particulièrement solennelle elle
concerne la République la défense des
libertés et des droits le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin a menacé
de manière à peine vous allez la Ligue
des droits de l'Homme de sanctions
financières il a déclaré il faut être
précis je ne connais pas la subvention
donnée par l'État mais ça mérite d'être
regardé dans le cadre des actions menées
madame la Première ministre les choses
sont claires votre Ministre de
l'Intérieur envisageait 100 sur sciller
remettre en cause les subventions à la
LDH car cette dernière avait exercé un
rôle d'observateur de vérification du
respect des libertés et des droits à
Sainte Soline ou sur d'autres théâtre
d'affrontement de tension ces menaces
sont d'une gravité insupportable
pouvez-vous accepter qu'un ministre de
la République envisage de porter
atteinte à une association qui est
l'honneur de cette dernière la Ligue des
droits de l'Homme vous le savez mais je
le rappelle a été créé pour défendre un
innocent victime de l'antisémitisme et
de la raison d'État le capitaine Dreyfus
elle a entendu d'emblée à la étendue
d'emblée son action à la défense de tout
citoyen victime d'une injustice ou d'une
atteinte à ces trois assez droit dès le
début du 20e siècle seul elle porte à la
justice sociale et les droits des
travailleurs madame la Première ministre
n'oublions pas à la Libération un tiers
du comité central de la LDH avait
disparu assassiné mort en déportation ou
fusillés Victor Basch son président fut
assassiné en 44 avec son épouse Ilona
par la milice et les nazis tout au long
du 20e siècle jusqu'à nos jours cette
grande association exhaçait avec
vigilance et Humanisme le contrôle des
excès des pouvoirs publics sans elle et
d'autres vigie l'autoritarisme nous
guette peut prendre le dessus avec 1000
personnalités qui ont déjà signé une
tribune publiée ce jour dans l'humanité
nous le disons fermement ne touchez pas
à la Ligue des droits de l'Homme je vous
demande madame la Première ministre
d'affirmer sans ambiguïté qu'aucune
menace ne pèse sur elle je vous demande
d'affirmer devant le Sénat que vous
désavouez les propos de votre Ministre
de l'Intérieur
pour vous répondre la parole des Cabana
la première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente Éliane assassin
depuis plusieurs semaines certains au
Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale dans des
interviews
ce qu'ils appellent une dérive
autoritaire
c'est une accusation tout aussi grave
que mensongère
notre État de droit et notre République
repose sur des libertés fondamentales
ces libertés nous les défendons et nous
les défendrons les associations de
défense des libertés publiques et des
droits de l'homme mènent également ce
combat et je crois que personne ici ne
peut contester sérieusement qu'elles ont
dans notre pays la capacité de prendre
position et de s'exprimer librement
pleinement sans restriction c'est
indispensable et nous veillerons à ce
que cela demeure
comme d'autres acteurs associatifs la
Ligue des droits de l'homme joue son
rôle en observant critiquant et exigeant
des réponses des acteurs publics et
lorsque l'État est mis en cause nous
écoutons nous le prenons en compte et je
souhaite comme tous les membres du
gouvernement que les associations de
soutien aux droits de l'homme
poursuivent leur action de vigie
d'ailleurs largement financé par l'État
et les collectivités il n'est donc pas
question de baisser par principe la
subvention de tels ou tel mais dialoguer
avec les associations sur leurs actions
est aussi une responsabilité dès lors
qu'il s'agit de financement public
madame la Présidente assassin pour
revenir sur la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme je connais l'histoire de cette
grande association
pendant longtemps l'histoire de
l'émancipation républicaine est celle de
la LDH se sont mêlés
l'universalisme était un terreau commun
il y a toujours eu des débats exigeants
des confrontations parfois sans remonter
à l'affaire Dreyfus je pense à
l'engagement de Madeleine reberio et de
mettre Henri Leclerc quand je regarde
l'appel au soutien à la LDH à la Une de
l'humanité ce matin je crois qu'au fond
c'est essentiellement à cette histoire
collective que les signataires disent
leur attachement
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ce que la
LDH a incarné je ne comprends plus
certaines de ces prises de position
cette incompréhension n'est pas nouvelle
elle s'est fait elle s'est fait jour
dans ses ambiguïtés face à l'islamisme
radical et elle s'est confortée depuis
quelques mois
et je rappelle que cette association a
attaqué un arrêté interdisant le
transport d'armes par destination à
Sainte Soline
cette incompréhension est partagée par
de nombreux acteurs associatifs et dans
une lettre adressée hier au président de
la commission nationale conçu
consultatif des droits de l'homme le
président de la lycra a dénoncé les
dérives et la défaillance de la Ligue
des droits de l'homme
madame la Présidente la liberté
d'expression et la liberté de manifester
pacifiquement son fondamental en
démocratie
avec le gouvernement avec la grande
majorité d'entre vous sur ces bancs je
veux rendre hommage aux policiers et aux
gendarmes qui connaissent leurs devoirs
d'exemplarité assure l'ordre républicain
dans notre pays et dont près de 1000
plus de 1800 ont été blessés depuis
début janvier
manifesté est un droit fondamental ça
n'est pas en excusant des violences
qu'on le défend au contraire il doit
pouvoir s'exercer dans la sécurité alors
nous continuerons à agir pour protéger
ce droit pour protéger les manifestants
pour protéger les Français je vous
remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole
est à notre collègue Didier Rambaud pour
le grau du rassemblement démocrate
progressistes et indépendants
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
comptes publics qu'elle soit fiscale
sociale ou douanières les fraudes sont
une réalité persistante en France
élément déterminant de notre contrat
social la lutte contre la fraude est un
sujet préoccupant un exemple de cause
commune qui doit faire Concorde dans un
contexte la maîtrise de nos finances
publiques s'impose plus que jamais face
aux crises que nous traversons notre
pays doit continuer d'agir dans la lutte
contre toutes les fraudes depuis la loi
du 28 octobre 2018 notre pays a
considérablement progressé en la matière
en témoigne les résultats records
obtenus en 2021 près de 11 milliards
d'euros recouvraient par le contrôle
fiscal penchant également à l'amende
record de plus d'un milliard d'euros
payés il y a un an par McDo l'année 2022
est également une année significative
les montants mis en recouvrement après
contrôle fiscal atteignent un niveau
inédit avec un total de 14,6 milliards
d'euros concernant la fraude
recouvrement social le réseau à plus que
doublé le montant des redressements
réalisés depuis 10 ans passant de 320
millions d'euros en 2013 à 788 millions
d'euros en 2022 sans oublier les
résultats de la douane qui sont à
nouveau historiques sur plusieurs
segments de fraude comme les
contrefaçons ou les trafics de tabac et
qui devraient je l'espère être
accompagné d'un renforcement de nos
outils dans la lutte contre la fraude
douanière grâce au projet à venir car en
effet des progrès peuvent indéniablement
être réalisés il y a quatre mois
monsieur le ministre nous débattirons
dans cette hémicycle sur la lutte contre
la fraude et l'évasion fiscale depuis un
travail de réflexion important associant
les parlementaires de tous les groupes a
été engagé sur votre impulsion avec pour
objectif d'aboutir à un plan d'action
monsieur le ministre que compte faire le
gouvernement pour continuer à renforcer
notre lutte contre la fraude sous toutes
ses formes
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des comptes
publics monsieur Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Didier Rambaud je veux le dire
solennellement devant vous la lutte
contre la fraude ça n'est pas qu'une
question de denier public c'est aussi et
probablement avant tout une question de
confiance dans l'action publique de
confiance de nos concitoyens de
confiance de cette classement moyenne
qui a parfois le sentiment de payer trop
parce que certains choisissent de ne
rien payer du tout et la lutte contre la
fraude c'est autant un enjeu de finances
publiques qu'un enjeu de cohésion
nationale et nous devons être
implacables pour renforcer la confiance
de nos concitoyens vis-à-vis de l'action
publique la renforcer évidemment en
mettant en avant les résultats
importants inédits que nous avons
obtenus et vous l'avez dit la loi de
2018 a été une étape majeure nous avons
connu l'an dernier une année historique
inédite en termes de droit mis en
recouvrement s'agissant de la fraude
fiscale nous avons aussi connu des
records en matière de fraude sociale
recouvrement de la fraude sociale
la deuxième manière de redonner
confiance c'est bien de s'attaquer à
toutes les fraudes moi je veux qu'on
arrête de segmenter les fraudes dans
certains cas on a l'impression qu'il n'y
aurait que de la fraude fiscale et dans
d'autres cas qu'il n'y aura que de la
fraude sociale nous devons nous attaquer
à toutes les fraudes qu'elles soient
fiscale sociale et dounières c'est le
sens du groupe de travail que j'ai mis
en place avec effectivement des
représentants de la quasi-totalité des
groupes politiques de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat nous nous sommes
réunis à plusieurs reprises ces derniers
mois nous avons beaucoup travaillé et je
présenterai dans les prochaines semaines
un plan complet de lutte contre les
fraudes fiscale sociale et douanières je
veux le dire je me suis appuyé pour
préparer ce plan sur beaucoup de travaux
sénatoriaux qui ont été menés je pense
aux travaux de Nathalie Goulet je pense
aux travaux du rapporteur général Husson
du président rénal un rapport important
a été remis et j'annoncerai notamment un
renforcement massif des moyens du sejf
du service d'enquête judiciaire des
Finances qui était une de vos
propositions je pense aux travaux du
sénateur
Boquet aussi sur ce sujet là nous nous
retrouverons dans les prochaines
semaines pour avancer ensemble vers une
plus grande fermeté des moyens plus
importants dans notre lutte contre les
fraudes
[Applaudissements]
la parole notre collègue Yann Chanel
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues madame la Première ministre à
Strasbourg dans la nuit du 21 au 22 mars
le planning familial 67 a subi une
attaque d'un groupe d'extrême droite en
tissoirs
de messages contre le droit à
l'avortement à Saint-Brévin le 22 mars
le maire a été victime d'un incendie
volontaire perpétré par l'extrême droite
intégriste et identitaire qui s'oppose
au déménagement du centre d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile dans sa ville à
Bordeaux le 23 mars des identitaires qui
menacent de mort le maire depuis des
mois ont mis feu à la porte de sa mairie
à Metz le 5 avril le chanteur Bilal
Hassani a dû annuler un concert suite
aux menaces d'un collectif d'extrême
droite catholique des groupuscules
identitaires comme les remparts à Lyon
ou l'oriflam à Rennes multiplie les
intimidations et les attaques
zeghnophynophobe et homophobe partout on
s'inquiète d'une résurgence des
violences extrême droite le directeur de
la DGSI déclarait récemment que ces
violences constituent la principale
menace à laquelle nous sommes confrontés
sur les 10 dernières attaques tentatives
d'attentat 7 venaient de l'extrême
droite madame la Première ministre le
mandat que les Français vous ont donné
au soir de second tour c'était d'être un
rempart contre l'extrême droite quant
allez-vous prendre enfin prendre la
mesure de votre échec et lutter de
manière implacable contre la montée de
l'extrême droite dans notre pays
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté madame baquet vous avez la
parole merci monsieur je suis le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
chanterelle je veux vous assurer de la
pleine mobilisation du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer notamment
de nos services de renseignements pour
anticiper et détecter la formation de
groupuscules qu'ils soient d'extrême
droite ou d'extrême gauche et qui sont à
l'origine de troubles à l'ordre public
le ministère de l'Intérieur fait preuve
de la plus grande fermeté en la matière
je vous rappelle également que nous
avons dissous une association d'extrême
droite les oeuvres de Paris qui
agissaient de manière extrêmement
violente en perpétrant un certain nombre
de délits à caractère raciste
antisémitiste lutte contre enfin en
guerre contre les les homosexuels etc
etc je rappelle également que les
pardons les socialistes ont déposé un
projet de résolution
visant à traiter la question des des
violences d'extrême droite et que donc
nous aurons l'occasion d'en débattre et
pour rappel également nous avons avec la
loi crpr qui a été adoptée en août 2021
tous les outils pour lutter le plus
efficacement possible contre tous ces
séparatistes je vous remercie
madame la Première ministre j'aurais
espéré que sur un sujet aussi grave pour
lequel vous avez mandat de la part des
Français vous y répondriez directement
non seulement votre gouvernement n'est
pas un rempart contre l'extrême droite
mais les provocations de votre Ministre
de l'Intérieur digne d'un régime
autoritaire l'alimente vous banalisez
dangereusement le terme de terrorisme
attaché à une mémoire si douloureuse
dans notre pays pour qualifier des
adversaires politiques vous menacez de
priver de subventions une association
comme la Ligue des droits de l'Homme
garant du respect de nos libertés
publiques vous n'êtes pas le rempart
contre l'extrême droite vous êtes sa
passerelle vers le pouvoir
la parole est à notre collègue Véronique
Guillotin pour leur groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chloro talonyl r 47 18 11 la France a
découvert ce nom la semaine dernière
après la publication des rapports de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
lors d'une étude de grande ampleur
lancès a retrouvé 77 pesticides et
résidus dans l'autre traité parmi eux le
chloro tallonie a attiré l'attention des
autorités puisque ces métabolites ont
été retrouvés dans plus d'un
prélèvements sur deux et ont même
dépassé la limite de qualité dans plus
d'un prélèvement sur trois je précise
bien la limite de qualité c'est donc au
moins un tiers de l'eau du robinet et
certaines eaux embouteillées qui
seraient non conformes à la
réglementation et pour cause les
filières de traitement conventionnel ne
parviennent pas à s'en débarrasser les
technologies pour lutter contre ce
métabolisme sont à la fois coûteuses et
énergivores ce fongicide longtemps
utilisé dans de nombreuses cultures et
considérées comme un cancérogène
probable depuis 2006 et interdit en
Europe depuis 2019 pourtant alors qu'on
l'on sait que certains un résidu de
pesticides peuvent être présents dans
l'environnement plusieurs années après
leur interdiction le chloro talonyle
n'avait jamais été recherché dans notre
eau potable alors qu'on sait que la
molécule provoque des tumeurs rénales
chez les souris les recherches sur la
santé humaine demeurent lacunaire or ces
recherches pourraient justement
permettre de rassurer la population voir
si c'est justifié d'abaisser le niveau
d'exigence sanitaire c'est un sujet
aussi sensible que l'accès à l'eau
potable dans un contexte de tension
croissante que nous connaissons autour
du partage de la ressource il nous faut
des éléments de réponse précis et des
solutions nationales à court et à long
terme sous peine d'aboutir à une
fracture de confiance mais aussi à une
fracture territoriale avec des petits
réseaux en zone rurale qui pèleraient à
investir dans les technologies adaptées
alors madame la ministre comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là mais surtout
quels sont les mesures envisagées pour
évaluer les risques sanitaires et
dépolluer nos eaux des réseaux d'eau
on vous répond
la parole est à Madame firme le Bodo au
ministre délégué en charge de
l'organisation territoriale et
professions de santé
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Guillotin j'ai eu l'occasion
de m'exprimer à ce sujet hier à
l'Assemblée nationale et je vous
remercie de me donner l'occasion de le
redire aujourd'hui devant vous l'eau et
notre bien le plus précieux et le
gouvernement met évidemment tout en
œuvre pour en assurer et surveiller sa
qualité c'est un enjeu majeur de santé
publique et la surveillance de la
qualité de l'eau est une préoccupation
quotidienne c'est bien pour cette raison
que sous l'autorité du ministère de la
Santé de la prévention la Direction
générale de la santé missionne
régulièrement les agences d'expertise
françaises pour disposer de
connaissances sanitaires sur les
pesticides et leur métabolites le but de
ces campagnes exploratoires c'est de
disposer des données les plus précises
possibles pour évaluer les risques
sanitaires l'ancêtre comme vous l'avez
dit à publier la semaine dernière les
principaux résultats de la dernière
campagne exploratoire 2020-2022 de
mesures relatives au polluant émergents
dans l'eau potable ce rapport met en
évidence une contamination des
ressources en eau destinée la
consommation humaine utilisée en France
métropolitaine
différents métabolites dont celui du
chloro talonyl infongicide interdit en
France depuis 2020 à ce stade et adapt
la campagne exploratoire de lancès a mis
en évidence des concentrations maximales
de deux microgrammes par litre la valeur
sanitaire transitoire permettant de
prévenir des risques d'assanitaires et
de 3 microgrammes par litre les
échantillons prélevés ne présentent donc
pas de risque sanitaires à ce stade
plusieurs responsables de la production
et de la distribution d'eau ont déjà
intégré le chloro talonyl et ses
métabolites dans leur plan de
surveillance le programme de contrôle
les ARS va progressivement intégrer à
partir de 2023 le chloro tallonie
laissait métabolites dans le contrôle
sanitaire des eaux pour rendre des
résultats fiables ces éléments
permettent de poursuivre le travail
d'amélioration de la qualité des eaux en
particulier pour les zones de captage et
adaptés différencier nos mesures par
rapport aux spécificités territoriales
comme l'a annoncé le président de la
République lors de la présentation du
plan o le 30 mars dernier vous le voyez
le gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
et suit ce sujet essentiel avec une
grande vigilance car l'eau c'est la vie
de qualité c'est la santé merci
[Musique]
madame Guillotin vous avez quelques
secondes si vous le souhaitez
de quelques secondes pour vous remercier
Madame la Ministre déjà pour la réponse
redire qu'effectivement il est quand
même important de différencier le seuil
de qualité et le seuil sanitaire et qui
paraît aujourd'hui quand même nécessaire
d'investir notamment dans la recherche
de la santé humaine afin vous l'avez dit
de donner le plus de précisions possible
pour mesurer notre qualité de l'eau qui
est indispensable
la parole était notre collègue joël
Labbé pour le groupe écologie solidarité
et territoire
monsieur le Président madame messieurs
les ministres chers collègues la semaine
dernière lancest a révélé ça a été dû
tout à l'heure qu'un tiers de notre eau
potable n'est pas conforme à la
réglementation mais le pire pour nous
c'est que monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture vous remettez en cause le
travail scientifique de l'inceste en
contestant ces décisions notamment sur
le retrait du S métalloclore la
crédibilité de votre politique de ce
fait sur les pesticides et sur la
qualité de l'eau s'effrite de jour en
jour que répondez-vous à la population
inquiète de boire de l'eau du robinet
que répondent et vous aux collectivités
qui s'interroge sur les coûts de
dépollution que répondez-vous aux
agriculteurs qui n'utilisent pas les
pesticides et qui n'ont aucune
responsabilité je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc
Feydeau merci monsieur le Président du
Sénat mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur la BM
merci de votre question d'abord pour
pour préciser un certain nombre de
choses à aucun moment vous pouvez
prendre tous les Verbatim nous étions
d'ailleurs dans une réunion hier
ensemble je n'ai remis en cause les
analyses scientifiques et les analyses
que faisaient l'on cesse j'ai simplement
posé une question si on a le droit
encore de poser des questions dans ce
pays c'est s'il n'y avait pas lieu
puisque nous sommes dans une agriculture
qui est dans un cadre européen de poser
la question de la synchronologie la
synchronisation et la chronologie de nos
décisions puisque sur la molécule en
question le S métola chlore personne ne
remet en cause l'étude dans le 16 il y a
un travail qui est fait au niveau
européen il y avait il me semble-t-il un
risque de désynchronisation c'est ça la
question que j'ai posée première élément
deuxième élément salut on quand même le
travail qui a été fait depuis des années
puis 2016 sur les molécules les plus les
plus à risque les cmr1 comme on dit 96%
de réduction depuis 2016 donc c'est un
élément tangible de ce que nous avons
fait au travers d'un certain nombre de
je pense en plan et cofito troisième
élément nous comptons allons aller plus
loin pour les raisons qui ont été
évoquées à l'instant on a besoin de
réduire l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires vous ne trouverez
toujours ce chemin la différence
peut-être que nous avons c'est qu'il me
semble que pour aller sur ce chemin il
faut le faire en bon ordre et dans le
cas d'une planification l'interdiction
je le répète ça ne produit pas la
solution l'interdiction ça produit de la
distorsion de concurrence au niveau
européen et ça produit le fait que à
l'extérieur de nos frontières
européennes dans le même espace de
marché il y a des gens qui produisent
avec des produits qui sont autorisés
chez eux on a donc besoin de travailler
en européen et deuxième élément on a
besoin de procéder à une planification
la planification c'est simple voilà ce
que nous allons faire et c'est ce qui a
été fait sous décider sous l'autorité de
la première ministre c'est de faire en
sorte que filière par filière molécule
par molécules nous regardions les
produits dont on sait qu'on doit dont on
doit sortir et quels sont les
alternatives et qu'on le fasse dans cet
ordre là pour faire en sorte qu'à chaque
fois qu'on produit une interdiction ou
qu'on a une perspective d'interdiction
on puisse produire une solution sinon je
vais vous dire ce qui va se passer
monsieur l'abbé il va se passer que nous
aurons nous n'aurons plus l'agriculture
et nous aurons des produits qui
viendront à l'intérieur de nos
frontières avec des productions dont
nous ne voulons pas
[Applaudissements]
monsieur l'abbé
que l'on prenne notre temps mais
lorsqu'il y a urgence on a plus le temps
de prendre notre temps au lieu de rester
sur la défensive vous auriez pu nous
parler de cette étude prospective de
l'INRA et vers une Europe sans
pesticides en 2050 études qui démontre
que c'est possible à condition de
définir des trajectoires pour
y parvenir sans rupture mais selon les
conclusions de cette étude cette
transition nécessite des politiques
publiques cohérentes et articulées
monsieur le ministre
je vais m'en aller tout bientôt alors je
me suis passé je me suis penché sur mon
passé de sénateur la quasi-totalité des
questions que j'ai posées depuis 2011 a
concerné la lutte contre les pesticides
et leurs méfaits ainsi que le soutien à
l'agriculture biologique qui n'utilise
pas les pesticides et préservent la
biodiversité aujourd'hui quand on fait
le bilan très peu de choses ont avancé
les pesticides sont toujours dans la
place sur le sol dans l'eau dans l'air
et l'agriculture biologique reste
toujours le parent pauvre cela malgré la
succession de ministre de l'Agriculture
alors je me dis avec des pi
les ministres passent la biodiversité et
la santé très passe et là
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Vanina
paoligaja pour le gros plus indépendants
République et territoires
madame la ministre le patrimoine
culturel immobilier c'est surtout ce que
nos ancêtres ont bâti au cours des
siècles les églises notamment qui
maillent l'ensemble de notre territoire
dans nos villes comme dans nos campagnes
ces édifices sont un très saillants du
visage de la France et contribue à sa
tenue et à son rayonnement
nous avons le devoir de préserver ces
richesses
hérités pour les transmettre aux
générations futures lesquelles à leur
tour en seront responsables cette noble
mission madame la ministre de
conservateur passeur nous incombe
aujourd'hui et nos communes sont en
première ligne puisqu'elles sont
propriétaires effectivement d'une grande
part des monuments et bâtiments
historiques face aux défis protéiforme
de la préservation patrimoniale dont
l'ampleur n'a de cesse d'enfler les
communes peinent à conserver et où à
valoriser ces trésors
elle rencontre également des difficultés
madame la ministre à les assurer car le
secteur privé n'a pas développé de
réponses Sidoine les élus locaux
notamment nos mères se sont démunis il
est urgent d'engager une vaste réflexion
autour de la préservation du patrimoine
communal et de la capacité de l'assurer
dès lors madame la ministre comment le
gouvernement appréhende-t-il la menace
qui pèse sur notre patrimoine comment
comptent-ils accompagner les communes
qui ne parviennent pas à trouver une
solution je vous remercie de votre
réponse
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la ministre de la
Culture Rima abdull Malak merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice paoligajin
j'adhère à chaque mot de votre constat
et à cette attachement que tous les
Français ont pour leur patrimoine
notamment dans les petites communes
j'étais hier à Conty dans la Somme
commune de 1800 habitants où j'ai pu
constater l'engagement de l'État mais de
l'ensemble des collectivités pour
restaurer l'église du 16e siècle nous
nous finançons à tort de 40% ses travaux
dans le cadre du fond incitatif pour le
patrimoine qui a un nouveau dispositif
lancé en 2018 dont j'ai augmenté le
budget de 12% en 2023 et qui permet
d'abonder le budget de l'État quand les
régions s'engagent ça a permis déjà
depuis 2018 de financer près de 600
chantiers et j'ai regardé ces 77% de ses
chantiers sont dans des communes de
moins de 1000 habitants donc voilà une
première réponse qui n'existait pas il y
a déjà quelques années ce budget si on a
pu l'amplifier c'est parce qu'il dans
une ambition très forte pour les
monuments historiques avec un budget
sans précédent qui atteint presque 470
millions d'euros en 2023 c'est 7% de
plus que l'année dernière mais c'est
surtout 40% de plus que le dernier
budget du quinquennat de François
Hollande donc c'est vraiment massif
comme investissement alors effectivement
là je vous parle des monuments
historiques puisque l'État à la
responsabilité depuis la loi de 2004 des
monuments protégés au type des monuments
historiques inscrits ou classés et vous
vous posez comme question au fond
l'enjeu du patrimoine non protégé ce
qu'on est au rendez-vous sur le
patrimoine protégé y compris dans les
petites communes aujourd'hui il y a deux
leviers qui existent il y a les fonds
interministériels des préfectures
qui la décile des hauter etc dans la
Somme hier c'était 4 millions par
exemple pour une centaine d'églises ces
fonds là il y a le loto du patrimoine
que nous avons créé la moitié des sites
sauvés par le loto sont des sites non
protégés mais évidemment il y a une
réflexion à avoir et que l'ensemble des
partenaires la Fondation du Patrimoine
les assureurs les collectivités pour
aller plus loin je vous l'accorde les
enjeux sont immenses et nous y sommes
hâte le ateliers merci beaucoup
merci madame la ministre nous pourrions
envisager quand même un fond d'aide
accessible à toutes les communes qui ne
sont pas en mesure d'assurer leur
patrimoine immobilier je pense qu'il
viendrait utilement compléter celui qui
est proposé par Monsieur Stéphane Bern
et ça permettrait de mobiliser
concrètement l'État aux côtés des
communes sur ce patrimoine qui ne relève
pas directement de sa compétence nous
devons ensemble relever le défi de la
préservation de ce patrimoine
remarquable
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Sophie prima pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie après le rachat par le
américain Aiko de l'entreprise excelia
fleuron français de l'électronique c'est
maintenant la PME Sego qui menace de
passer sous pavillon américain pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ne la connaissent pas
mes chers collègues la PME c'est gaufres
fabrique entre autres les pièces de
robinetterie de haute technologie qui
équipe nos centrales nucléaires les
chaufferies de nos sous-marins
nucléaires ou encore celle de notre
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle c'est
pourquoi j'associe le président Cambo à
ma question
indispensable au nucléaire civil comme
militaire Sego entre a donc à double
titre dans le champ des secteurs
stratégiques visés par la réglementation
sur le contrôle des investissements
étrangers si nous ne pouvons pas
envisager que cette entreprise passe
sous contrôle américain monsieur le
ministre c'est parce que le patriote Act
permet aux États-Unis de demander
l'accès à tout type d'informations
détenus par une entreprise américaine
quel que soit la localisation dans le
monde et ceci sans aucune justification
ainsi sur le champ de compétences de ses
Go des informations même partielles sur
la conception de nos infrastructures
nucléaires pourraient être transmises
sans obstacle juridique il y a donc un
double un double enjeu de souveraineté
industrielle et militaire aujourd'hui le
président de la République se gargarise
d'avoir gagné la bataille idéologique de
l'autonomie stratégique alors chiche
vous avez ici un magnifique cas
d'espèces quels outils juridiques et
quels moyens financier allez vous
mobiliser pour que ces gos puissent
revenir durablement dans le giron
français allez-vous activer monsieur le
ministre le décret de 2014 relatif au
contrôle des investissements étrangers
allez vous rechercher des acquéreurs
souverains
[Applaudissements]
en charge de la transition numérique des
télécommunications monsieur Barrault
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente Sophie prima vous l'avez dit
Sego est un robinettier français fleuron
de l'industrie nucléaire française qui
intervient principalement dans la
fabrication des sous-marins nucléaires
mais également sur les réacteurs
nucléaires c'est la raison pour laquelle
Roland Lescure aurait dû répondre à
votre question aujourd'hui je vous prie
d'excuser son absence il est retenu aux
côtés du Président de la République au
Pays-Bas aujourd'hui cego est
actuellement détenu par l'entreprise
canadienne volant la famille veland a
communiqué récemment sur des discussions
poussées en cours avec un autre grand
robinetier américain qui s'appelle flow
surf un accord de rachat par flotteur
des activités de vélo incluant ses Go
pourrait avoir lieu d'ici l'été bien sûr
nous sommes particulièrement vigilants
ici parce que Sego est une entreprise
stratégique et parce que les États-Unis
vous l'avez rappelé dispose d'une
réglementation particulièrement
offensive qui pourrait menacer la
confidentialité et la souveraineté des
informations relatives aux technologies
développées chez Sego cette opération
sera évidemment soumise à la procédure
de contrôle des investissements
étrangers le ministère de l'Économie
avec le concours du ministère des armées
et du ministère de l'Énergie statura sur
les risques d'un tel rachat et sur les
suites à donner
oui monsieur le ministre en 2015 le
ministre de l'Économie d'alors a commis
l'erreur stratégique de pousser à la
session d'arabel et de cette urbine
nucléaire général électrique dans le
cadre du rachat d'Alstom je vous engage
à ne pas faire deux fois la même erreur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Pascal à
l'Isère pour le groupe irrépublicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 8
janvier
1964 il y aura bientôt 60 ans le général
de Gaulle au Conseil des ministres
déclarait que la Chine est là vivre
comme si elle n'existait pas c'est être
aveugle le 27 janvier suivant la
reconnaissance par la France de la
République populaire de Chine était
annoncée dans un environnement
international pas forcément plus
conciliant que celui que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui quelle vision le
président de la République rentre de
Chine et nous approuvons ce voyage qui
finalement nous confirme que la Chine
garde son cap en fonction de ses seules
intérêts stratégiques dès lors monsieur
le ministre pourquoi cette déclaration à
l'emporte-pièce sur Taïwan entre Europe
Chine et États-Unis quelle est la
stratégie française
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes
délégué porte-parole du gouvernement sur
le ministre monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Pascal Alizard à
nouveau j'excuse l'absence de la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colonna qui était en
déplacement et pardonnez-moi en matière
de diplomatie j'ai plutôt tendance à me
référer aux éléments diplomatiques
mûrement réfléchis qui me sont fournis
vous l'avez rappelé le président de la
République à effectuer une visite d'État
en Chine du 5 au 8 avril il était
accompagné d'ailleurs par la présidente
de la Commission européenne cette visite
répondait à plusieurs objectifs d'une
part relancer la relation en particulier
dans le domaine des échanges humains à
ce titre des accords ont ainsi été
conclus dans le domaine du développement
durable de la coopération culturelle et
de l'économie agroalimentaire
aéronautique notamment
d'autre part l'enjeu était d'avoir un
dialogue franc sur l'Ukraine le
président a fait valoir les positions
aux européennes à appeler la Chine à
s'engager dans la recherche d'une
solution à alerter son homologue chinois
sur les conséquences que tout soutient
militaire à la Russie aurait sur la
relation entre l'Union européenne et
Chine des points de convergence sont
ainsi apparus l'opposition à l'emploi de
l'arme nucléaire le respect du droit
international humanitaire la nécessité
de trouver une issue au conflit sur la
base du droit international par ailleurs
un autre enjeu de se déplacement celui
de marquer notre unité européenne la
présence de la présidente de la
commission était un point essentiel pour
le président de la République qui tenait
à montrer que les Européens ont leur
propre intérêts et les a su dans un
dialogue exigeant avec Pékin enfin
monsieur le sénateur le souhait de la
France vous le savez de travailler à un
agenda commun avec la Chine sur les
enjeux globaux le président de la
République a ainsi souligné la dynamique
positive dans le domaine du climat de la
biodiversité il a invité la Chine au
sommet de juin sur le nouveau pacte
financier qui a indiqué qu'elle
historique représentée à haut niveau sur
la question de Taïwan j'ai eu l'occasion
de répondre sur une précédente question
identique j'ai évité une redite monsieur
le sénateur je vous remercie
je suis Alison
sur le ministre le rapprochement Russo
chinois qui est un fait géopolitique est
un fait sur lequel nous n'avons eu
aucune prise la France est attachée je
le crois fermement aux droits à la
liberté de navigation à l'avenir de
l'Indo-Pacifique et ne peut rester
étrangère à la montée des tensions
autour de Taïwan où les incursions
militaires chinoises sont de plus en
plus fréquentes et structurées sur les
États-Unis avec quelques collègues nous
avions intitulé un récent rapport ami
allié mais pas aligné pour illustrer
notre relation malgré leurs Inn élégance
australienne les Américains demeurent
tout de même nos alliés ultimes et dans
les faits nous ne sommes d'ailleurs pas
capables de soutenir un conflit de haute
intensité nos partenaires de l'Union
européenne le sont encore moins une
tentative d'action de vifort sur Taïwan
par la Chine comme ce fulcan en Ukraine
par la Russie n'est plus à exclure
l'armée populaire s'y prépare au
quotidien et je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent dans toutes ses
déclarations je vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Claude Rousseau pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé la semaine dernière
le conseil de surveillance du Centre
Hospitalier du foret a acté la fermeture
des urgences de Feurs dans mon
département de la Loire les plus proches
sont désormais à Montbrison soit pour
des milliers de personnes à plus de 30
minutes de route or comme vous le savez
très bien c'est 30 minutes sont un seuil
critique au-delà duquel la perte de
chance est réelle un inquiétude des
patients s'ajoute les alertes des
professionnels du soin les pompiers
volontaires nous disent ainsi que la
longueur des trajets pour rejoindre le
nouveau centre d'urgence risque non
seulement de rendre les employeurs
réticents à les laisser à laisser leurs
salariés s'engager mais de dissuader des
volontaires eux-mêmes cette situation
n'est pas isolée les risques de
fermeture d'urgence ou de maternité se
multiplient à l'hôpital suggéron de
Langon La Réole à l'hôpital de
Carpentras sur les centres hospitaliers
de Guingamp et de Carhaix où l'hôpital
de Ruffec en Charente dans tous ces
hôpitaux l'entrée en application de la
loi risque qui encadrent la rémunération
des intérimaires agit comme un
détonateur il est certes nécessaire et
nous disions ici sur nos bancs pour
lutter contre le mercenariat mercenaria
de certains intérimaires qui crèvent les
budgets hospitaliers mais en ne ciblant
que les établissements publics et sans
travail sur l'attractivité de l'hôpital
la mesure ne pouvait qu'avoir des effets
pervers nous envoyons aujourd'hui les
conséquences qu'allez-vous faire
monsieur le ministre pour y remédier
pour faire une solution alternative
proposée par la chef des urgences madame
Massacrier le docteur massacrié
permettrait de maintenir une ligne de
garde d'urgence jusqu'en juin solution
que j'ai proposé à votre cabinet
autoriserez vous monsieur le ministre
c'est très organisation s'est
organisations afin de maintenir le
service ouvert le temps de trouver
d'autres solutions concernant les
intérimaires allez-vous rétablir
l'équité de traitement entre
établissement public et privé il est
clair que le Ségur n'a pas suffi à
redonner de l'attractivité aux carrière
médicale hospitalière monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre allez-vous
enfin proposer une réforme d'ampleur
pour revaloriser les salaires et
améliorer les conditions de travail de
l'hôpital ou attendez-vous qu'il y a
encore 10 50 sans fermeture comme à
faire
pour répondre à la parole est communique
de la santé de la prévention monsieur
Braun merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Tissot je vous
remercie d'avoir rappelé ici le
consensus qu'il y a autour de la mise en
application de la loi rise et son
article 33 sur le plafonnement de
l'intérim médical c'est bien sûr contre
les dérives de l'intérim médical que
nous luttons est absolument pas contre
le principe même de cet intérêt médical
pourquoi nous luttons contre ces dérives
parce qu'elle menace justement notre
service public hospitalier par un effet
aspirateur de nos praticiens
hospitaliers vers ces dérives de
l'intérim qui a très court terme vont
détruire encore plus de services et
encore plus d'établissements bien
entendu cette lutte contre l'intérim
elle va de pair avec un travail que je
mène avec les représentants des médecins
hospitaliers sur l'amélioration des
conditions de travail à l'hôpital et de
ses médecins hospitaliers pour justement
les faire revenir pour ceux qui sont
partis et maintenir ceux qui sont
toujours en place
comme je m'y suis engagé nous avons
travaillé des solutions territoire par
territoire avec les professionnels de
santé avec les élus avec les
représentants également des patients et
la RS pour que la continuité des soins
soit assurée et je me réjouis qu'il y a
des propositions particulières surfeurs
d'autant que faire vous le savez très
bien est en grande difficulté
structurelle depuis plusieurs mois voire
année avec des fermetures
itératives ces fermetures étant la
plupart du temps aussi lié à ces dérives
de l'intérim médical je me réjouis quand
même qu'une solution a été trouvée avec
Montbrison qui est distant de 20 km les
urgences vitales étaient déjà assurées
par Montbrison depuis longtemps elle
continue à l'être pour ce qui est des
autres urgences nous travaillons pour
justement trouver une solution locale
plus pérenne
en ce qui concerne l'ensemble des eaux
d'établissements vous en avez signalé
plusieurs les services d'urgence il y a
effectivement Langon qui est en
difficulté pour laquelle nous
travaillons en ce qui concerne vous
parliez de Guingamp c'est plus un
problème qui est lié pour la maternité
de Guingamp pour laquelle là aussi c'est
un problème structurel qui date
malheureusement de plusieurs mois voire
année nous travaillons nous surveillons
au plus près l'ensemble de ces
situations pour adapter le territoire
par territoire et l'amélioration des
conditions de travail à l'hôpital fera
l'objet de présentation suite au rapport
que j'ai demandé avant la fin du mois de
juin je vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue Chantal
de Seine pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture à partir du 25
avril la France interdit d'exporter ses
céréales en dehors de l'Union Européenne
en cause la fausse fine insecticide
considérée comme dangereux par lande
cesse mais pas par nos partenaires
européens c'est insecticide utilisé pour
la fumigation des cales de bateau
céréaliers est exigée par les
importateurs de cargaison de blé
notamment vers les pays extra-européens
en particulier pour nos marchés en
Afrique du nord et de l'ouest or
l'anxess a décidé de façon unie de
latérale de ne plus permettre l'usage de
la fausse fine en contact direct avec
les céréales elle reste pourtant
homologuée paradoxalement les céréales
importées en France continueront elles à
être traité à la fosse fine aucune
réglementation européenne n'interdit en
effet l'utilisation de cette insecticide
c'est un non-sens total comment lancer
a-t-elle pu édicter une telle règle sans
concertation a-t-on bien mesuré les
conséquences de cette interdiction cette
sentence est également dramatique pour
les pays du bassin méditerranéen qui
dépendent de la France et dont la
sécurité alimentaire et menacée par
cette décision absurde aussi Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais connaître les
solutions que le gouvernement peut
proposer pour préserver nos exportations
de céréales et empêcher les crises
alimentaires dans les pays qui dépendent
de nos exportations
envisagez-vous de ré-autoriser l'usage
de la fausse fine indépendamment de la
décision de lande sèche je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de sel merci de votre question
j'ai déjà d'ailleurs répondu hier à
l'Assemblée nationale mais c'est pas un
proche ça me permet de repréciser un
certain nombre de choses et veut dire
les choses suivantes la France va se
mettre en situation de pouvoir continuer
à exporter les céréales après le 25
avril 2023 c'est fondé sur trois motifs
le premier c'est un motif que vous avez
évoqué vous-même c'est un motif de
garder notre capacité d'exportation
c'est une des puissances françaises en
termes agricoles et agroalimentaire que
d'être en capacité de livrer des
céréales à l'extérieur de nos frontières
et ça fait partie d'une de nos forces y
compris de nos forces politiques à
l'extérieur de nos frontières le
deuxième sujet c'est que c'est un sujet
vous l'avez dit de sécurité alimentaire
mondiale au moment où la guerre en
Ukraine ou la crise en Ukraine ou la
guerre menée par Monsieur Poutine a
déstabiliser les marchés mondiaux avec
des risques de fluctuation de prix et
même de d'accès à ces céréales on a
besoin d'avoir des marchés qui soient
fluides et de faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des pays qui en ont besoin
puisse avoir accès aux céréales
troisième élément il est fondé en droit
à la vérité il est possible dans le
droit européen le réglementation le
permet de faire en sorte que quand bien
même une molécule est interdite au
niveau national il puisse déroger dès
lors qu'elle est encore autorisée au
niveau européen sous réserve que ça soit
la demande du pays importateur et c'est
donc ça et c'est dans ce cadre là que
nous travaillons avec l'ancêtre pour
faire en sorte que en règle de droit
d'abord et c'est là-dessus que nous
travaillons nous puissions exporter à
partir de nouveau afin jusqu'au jusqu'à
présent et deuxième élément que nous
puissions répondre à l'exigence qui est
celle des temps c'est de faire en sorte
que la souveraineté des pays tiers la
souveraineté alimentaire des pays tiers
on voit bien à quel point l'arme
alimentaire est utilisée par un certain
nombre de gens en l'occurrence par la
Russie on ne peut pas se laisser
entraîner dans cette voie là et donc
comme d'autres pays européens comme les
allemands comme les Bulgares comme les
Roumains nous allons continuer nous
mettre en situation continuer exporter
des céréales ce n'est pas seulement
l'intérêt de la France
c'est l'intérêt de la sécurité
alimentaire mondiale
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse qui lève quelques inquiétudes
pour la filière mais aussi merci pour
votre engagement à sortir de cette
situation
ubuesque toutefois les acteurs de la
filière ont besoin d'une assise
juridique solide et pérenne donc
j'entends vos engagements mais il serait
bienvenu qu'il soit des engagements
écrits dans la durée le temps je vous
remercie merci
notre collègue Jean-Marie maison pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président j'associe à
ma question le sénateur de la Somme
Stéphane demi madame la ministre de
nombreuses communes se trouvent
confrontées à une situation bien
compliquée du fait de l'automatisation
du fond de compensation de la TVA cette
modification présentée comme technique à
l'origine abruti en effet à les privés
de la récupération de la TVA sur des
travaux lourds dit d'agencement et
d'aménagement de terrain ce qui exclut
nombre de chantiers comme par exemple
des terrains de football des aires de
jeux ou encore des pistes cyclables
surtout cette réglementation comporte
des éléments de complexité
supplémentaire avec au sein d'un même
projet des dépenses qui restent
éligibles et d'autres qui ne le sont
plus oubliant qu'un projet est un tout
aussi ma première question est simple
envisagez-vous de revenir sur cette
réglementation très mal vécue par les
collectivités locales ou à tout le moins
d'intégrer la part de TVA de l'assiette
subventionnelle ma deuxième question est
plus simple encore et pense sur un sujet
connexe trouvez-vous normal que les
communes apprennent fin mars seulement
voir début avril les montants de
dotation de fonctionnement qui leur sont
alloués par l'État
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée chargée des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité madame Faure
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Mison
en effet vous avez raison
l'automatisation du FCTVA conduit à une
redéfinition de l'assiette des dépenses
ouvrant droit à compensation pour
collecter les données comptables
nécessaires aux calculs automatique des
attributions certaines dépenses ont été
exclues de la sieste dont des dépenses
engagées par les collectivités telles
que celles que vous avez cité d'autres
dépenses qui n'étaient pas éligibles le
sont désormais comme des investissements
réalisés par des collectivités pour des
biens immobiliers qu'elles mettent à la
disposition de tiers et ces arbitrages
en son temps ont été pris en accord avec
des associations d'élus locaux et avec
le CFL
les incidences financières de
l'automatisation de la gestion du FCTVA
doivent être considérées de manière
globale si si si le CFL en plus je l'ai
vérifié le CFL a été associé les
incidences financières de
l'automatisation de la gestion du FCTVA
doivent considérer de manière globale
représente une mesure favorable aux
collectivités permet une disparition du
non recours qui concernait jusqu'à
présent les plus petites d'entre elles
mais une évaluation sera conduite
mi-2023
la question des dépenses d'aménagement
de terrain sera regardé de très près
monsieur le sénateur dans la suite des
débats que nous avons eu durant le PLF
concernant les délais de mise en ligne
des résultats de la répartition de la
DGF en fait ils ont très souvent
respectés ils l'ont été cette année avec
une mise en ligne le 31 mars permettant
aux collectivité de disposer 15 jours de
disposer de 15 jours pour l'inscrire
dans leur budget oui c'est très court
mais je veux quand même dire que cette
mise en ligne au 31 mars pour l'avoir
vécu à nécessité un travail très
important des agents de la DGCL et que
je remercie ici ce délai permet de
s'assurer de la fiabilité des calculs
réalisés il s'agit en effet de répartir
selon des règles
de critères près de 27 milliards d'euros
je m'engage pour autant à demander à la
DGCL pour l'année 2024 que l'objectif de
répartition de le ramener une semaine au
23 mars
et je vous tiendrai informé merci à vous
monsieur Mison
merci Madame et ministre on vous
écoutant votre réponse m'a fait penser à
ce que disait André Maurois le difficile
dans une discussion ce n'est pas de
défendre son opinion c'est de la
connaître et c'est à peu le problème de
ce gouvernement
parce que on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas un jour vouloir
construire 5000 5000 équipements
sportifs et le lendemain sortir de la
dépense éligible les échanges des
dépenses qui le constituent
on ne peut pas avoir de mots assez forts
pour défendre les vertus de la
simplification et de mettre des
barrières supplémentaires parce que vous
obligez les portes des porteurs de
projets aller décortiquer pour pouvoir
récupérer le peu de TVA qu'il reste
doutez madame la ministre que les
réalités doivent se plier aux règles
administratives et comptables mettez les
choses dans l'ordre et vous verrez ça
ira mieux merci
la parole est à notre collègue François
bonhomme pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse Miss réintérieur
monsieur le ministre à la suite des
violences qui sont produites à
Sainte-Souline vous avez affirmé devant
la commission des lois la semaine
dernière au Sénat être prêt à regarder
la subvention annuelle versée par l'État
à l'association la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme
aussitôt inévitablement nous avons
assisté à une véritable vide bouclier or
cette association au motif d'un passé
glorieux bénéficie de toute l'élargesses
de l'État quoi qu'elle fasse et
s'exonère de toute explication sur la
façon dont tu utilises ces moyens
alloués il est étonnant que cette
association sollicite et prospère avec
l'argent public pour s'opposer
systématiquement à l'état à le combattre
particulièrement dans sa difficile
mission de maintien de l'ordre public
droit fondamental si l'année
il y a dans cette instrumentalisation
systématique du droit une dérive qui
nous interroge comment l'État peut-il
soutenir et subventionner des
associations qui font profession de
jeter l'eau propre sur les forces de
l'ordre particulièrement face à des
groupes violents et armés qui cherchent
à tuer nos policiers et nos gendarmes
depuis votre déclaration avez-vous pu
monsieur le ministre regardez la
subvention de l'État versé à cette
association
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la secrétaire d'État en
charge de la citoyenneté madame baquet
l'absence de Gérald Darmanin qui
accompagne le président de la République
au Pays-Bas et puis permettez-moi de
rappeler le contexte de la prise de
parole du ministre que vous avez
interrogé dans le cadre d'une audition
en commission sur la possibilité de
supprimer les subventions à cette
association ça a été rappelé la Ligue
des droits de l'homme est une
association ancienne et respectable dans
le nom a été associé il est vrai à des
combats qu'il faut honneur à la
République pour autant certaines de ces
prises de position récente interrogent
et ce n'est pas lui faire un jure que de
le reconnaître je citerai ici leur
absence au procès des attentats de
Charlie Hebdo en 2020 ou encore leur
décision difficile à comprendre je dois
dire de défendre le collectif islamiste
CCIF au moment où le gouvernement a pris
la décision de le dissoudre du fait de
ses mener séparatistes on peut ajouter
nos regrets que la LDH colporte pardon
des rumeurs désormais prouvés comme
infondées visant à faire croire que les
gendarmes auraient empêché les secours
d'intervenir à Sainte Soline
le ministre de l'Intérieur est des
Outre-mer a simplement voulu rappeler
que la LDH bénéficier d'un soutien
conséquent de la part des pouvoirs
publics et vous l'avez dit nous parlons
ici d'argent public c'est-à-dire des
impôts de nos concitoyens et il s'agit
de 276000 euros pour l'État et de 233000
euros pour les collectivités
territoriales il est donc légitime que
l'État s'assure que les actions
conduites par une association qui
bénéficie de financement public sont en
phase avec l'objectif qu'elle déclare et
également en face avec nos valeurs
républicaines c'est ce que le MI le
ministre de l'Intérieur et les autres
mères vous a indiqué en réponse à votre
question en commission et que qui vous a
été confirmé par la première ministre je
vous remercie merci
Monsieur Bonhomme
merci monsieur le Président moi j'aurais
bon monsieur Darmanin est un vadrouille
je comprends madame Schiappa qui quand
même secrétaire d'État la vie
associative peut-être elle s'exprime
partout d'ailleurs sauf au Sénat bon
quant à la première ministre maintenant
le premier j'ai bien entendu votre
réponse tout à l'heure je la regrette je
vais vous dire parce que la Ligue des
droits de l'Homme sélectionne
soigneusement ses indignations ça a été
dit par la ministre à l'instant elle a
défendu les militants du CCIF après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty est la
défendu les tests de l'extrême gauche au
mot d'ordre la police tu et quand vient
même elle met toute son énergie pour
multiplier les recours de vallée
juridiction devant toute décision de
l'État y compris les flux migratoires et
en l'espèce à Sainte Soline c'était
contre le transport d'armes et en plus
elle diffusait des fausses informations
laissant entendre que le SAMU aurait été
délibérément empêché de porter secours
tout cela mériterait vraiment qu'on
regarde à plus près et ce que je vous
reproche madame la ministre c'est votre
faiblesse parce que vous avez dit Madame
toute mesure restrictives alors que
votre mission c'est de contrôler
l'argent public de l'État
[Applaudissements]
la parole à notre collègue à ni le héros
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci
madame la première ministre vous avez
fait adopter la réforme des retraites en
tordant l'esprit de notre Constitution
pour une réforme à tout prix vous avez
utilisé un plfs rectificatif l'article
47 a un puits 44-3 pour éviter un 49-3
et finir malgré tout par un 49-3 une
méthode faisant fit de l'expression
démocratique faisant fit de ce qu'on
exprimer les électeurs dans les urnes
pour éviter le pire en espérant que
notre président de la République saurait
en tenir compte or en retour après 11
journée de très forte mobilisation dans
une grande responsabilité inter
syndicale le président reste sourd comme
lui votre gouvernement prend une
attitude arrogante votre auto
satisfaction démontre combien vous êtes
déconnecté des réalités de nos
concitoyens vous méprisez la terre
syndicale uni contre cette réforme vous
mépriser l'opposition parlementaire
celle du Sénat en ayant utilisé tous les
artifices pour brider le débat vous
méprisez les millions de Françaises et
de Français qui manifestent leur
opposition depuis des mois dans la rue
et ce malgré l'inflation qui grève déjà
à leur budget familial face à la colère
qui s'exprime vous restez insensible au
revendications légitimes ainsi vous
affaiblissez nos institutions notre
démocratie et notre modèle social cette
réforme laissera des séquelles profondes
dans notre pays ces dernières semaines
vous avez usé de tous les stratagèmes
jusqu'au magazine People pour faire
diversion et tenter de tourner la page
de cette séquence mais les Français ne
sont pas dupes ils n'oublieront pas
votre réforme est inutile et injuste
c'est une régression sociale madame la
Première ministre vous êtes dans
l'impasse comment entendez-vous
gouverner après avoir méprisé à ce point
les corps intermédiaires comment
entendez-vous apaiser les tensions et
Renou er le dialogue social je ne vois
qu'une issue le retrait de la réforme
des retraites
[Applaudissements]
paroles du gouvernement monsieur Véran
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Annie le héros
il m'est déjà arrivé de me trouver en
situation plus confortable pour répondre
à une question d'un sénateur ou d'une
sénatrice un héros nous avons siéger
ensemble sur les mêmes bancs dans le
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale en 2014 et il me déplairait de
vous être désagréable et pourquoi est-ce
qu'il me déplierait de vous être
désagréable à vous en particulier madame
la sénatrice parce que lorsqu'il a fallu
réformer les retraites en 2014 j'étais
là pour voter la réforme et vous étiez
là pour voter la réforme je voudrais
reprendre je voudrais reprendre je
voudrais reprendre les mots sur lesquels
vous êtes appuyé à l'époque dans
l'hémicy qui se trouve que nous avions
intervenu nous étions intervenus l'un
après l'autre au pupitre de l'Assemblée
nationale vous aviez dit nous avons
besoin d'une réforme responsable qui
tient compte de la réalité que constitue
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
depuis 10 ans madame la sénatrice
l'espérance de vie s'est allongée et
l'équilibre que vous souhaitiez comme
une valeur de gauche à l'époque du
système des retraites il est en danger
aujourd'hui et la même manière qu'il y a
10 ans vous avez allongé la durée de
cotisation à 43 années que nous l'avons
voté ensemble c'est à nous en
responsabilité aujourd'hui de prendre
des décisions qui conviennent pour faire
en sorte que les générations futures
puissent elles aussi disposer d'un
système de retraite par répartition
équilibrée alors on peut s'envoyer tous
les meufs fleuris on peut parler de
toutes les argusies juridiques
légistiques on a les députés madame la
sénatrice vous ne souhaitiez pas partie
des Francs 2 vous aviez voté avec moi et
vous en portiez avec moi contre ceux qui
bloquaient vous savez ce que c'est que
bloquer le Parlement vous savez ce que
c'est que vous leur bloquer l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat et vous emportiez
comme moi contre seul celles et ceux qui
parce qu'ils étaient en désaccord sur le
fond vous voulez empêcher le débat au
Parlement de se tenir donc Madame la
saleterie je suis sûr qu'au fond au fond
de vous vous êtes capable de vous
retrouver avec nous sur une ligne
responsable et qui reconnaît que les
conditions du débat nous ont conduit
effectivement à recourir à la fin du
chemin démocratique un 49-3
la parole est à notre collègue Annie
Delmont kuropolis pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la santé et de
la prévention monsieur le ministre ce
n'est malheureusement plus à démontrer
les zones blanches médicales concernent
tous les territoires et les aides
financières ponctuelles ne permettent
pas à elle seule d'attirer les jeunes
médecins le Sénat a adopté l'an dernier
la PPL du président Bruno otaïo qui crée
une année de professionnalisation pour
les internes en médecine générale en fin
de cursus le dispositif prévoit que les
étudiants en médecine générale
effectuent une quatrième année
d'internat sous forme d'un stage en
pratique ambulatoire dans les zones
caractérisées par des difficultés dans
l'accès aux soins chaque année près de
4000 internes seraient ainsi déployés
dans les zones soudées l'article 37 de
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 prévoit à dispos
analogue les étudiants resteraient dans
la région où ils ont suivi leurs études
et bénéficieraient d'une rémunération
adaptée monsieur le ministre vous avez
confié une mission à des personnalités
qualifiées sur la refonte du troisième
cycle de médecine générale pouvez-vous
nous faire part de ces conclusions et
pouvez-vous nous préciser la date
d'entrée en vigueur de l'article 37 de
la LFSS
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes de la santé de la prévention
François Brown merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice d'Elmont
coraux police effectivement comme si
engagé le président de la République
nous mettons en place cette quatrième
année de spécialité de médecine générale
à compter de la rentrée prochaine c'est
d'ailleurs une quatrième année qui fait
consensus comme vous l'avez rappelé par
la PPL qui avait été déposée par le
président Retailleau et qui a été adopté
dans cette hémicycle cette quatrième
année à deux objectifs principaux un
objectif de formation pour nos futurs
médecins généralistes la médecine
générale était la seule spécialité
jusqu'à présent qui n'a pas cette
quatrième année d'autonomie supervisée
qui permet de mieux travailler et de
mieux former nos futurs médecins
généralistes particulièrement dans des
spécialités qu'ils demandent eux-mêmes
d'ailleurs la pédiatrie et la gynéco
obstétrique cette quatrième année va
permettre également de
faciliter l'installation de ses futurs
médecins généralistes déjà en les
déployant prioritairement dans les
territoires soudains c'est ce que vous
avez souhaité également ici mais
également leur permettant de passer plus
vite leur thèse de doctorat en médecine
puisque pour accéder à cette quatrième
année il devront être aisés ainsi donc
nous n'aurons pas des étudiants qui ne
peuvent pas s'installer pendant
plusieurs années en attendant de pouvoir
passer leur thèse
en ce qui concerne la mission que j'ai
effectivement confié à quatre personnes
qualifiées de professeurs de médecine
générale indien et une interne ils vont
me rendre leur conclusion dans les jours
qui viennent la question principale et
vous l'avez bien dit et celle de la
rémunération qui sera une rémunération
adaptée à cet exercice particulier qui
est un exercice qui ne fait pas ce cet
exercice de docteur junior en centre
hospitalier mais en libéral donc dès que
bien entendu les conclusions seront
remises je serai à votre disposition à
disposition du Sénat pour vous présenter
l'ensemble des tenues de ce rapport nous
allons pouvoir ainsi améliorer la
formation faciliter l'installation et
donc commencer par cette mesure à
répondre à notre problématique
d'inégalité d'accès territorial à la
santé je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre et juste un
petit rappel à l'initiative du Sénat la
loi du 24 juillet 2019 relative à
l'organisation et à la transformation du
système de santé prévoyait l'obligation
pour les étudiants de 3e cycle de
médecine générale d'effectuer un stage
d'au moins 6 mois en médecine
ambulatoire cette mesure n'a jamais été
mise en place
tout en regrettant le temps perdu nous
nous réjouissons que le Sénat est enfin
été entendu merci
la parole est à notre collègue Catherine
procacia pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires après un premier rapport
en 2009 l'OPEX vient de faire le point
sur la situation de la pollution par la
chlordécone aux Antilles en effet bien
que l'usage de cette molécule soit
interdite depuis 30 ans elle persiste
dans les sols dans les eaux elle
contamine les légumes racines des
animaux les poissons et par conséquent
les hommes par le biais de
l'alimentation si le rapport évoque les
progrès des connaissances scientifiques
et médicales il dresse un constat que
certains qualifient de sévères sur une
certaine
inefficacité des plantes lors des cônes
qui se sont succédés
inefficacité qui explique le sentiment
de défiance et de colère des Antillais
sa conclusion est hélaste d'actualité ce
qui est arrivé aux Antilles doit servir
de modèle à l'état pour gérer les
pollutions que nous ne manquerons pas de
découvrir une vision à long terme
s'appuyant sur la recherche et associant
tous les acteurs et dorénavant
nécessaire mais collègues m'ont
précédemment évoqué la pollution des
eaux signalées par landeces par une
molécule qui tout comme la chlordécone
est interdite mais persistante dans la
durée ma question est simple avez-vous
mis au point une stratégie qui permette
de faire face à ses contaminations une
stratégie réfléchie qui englobe les
aspects sanitaires économiques sociaux
environnementaux comment comptez-vous
associer et informer clairement la
population pour éviter le contre modèle
de la chlordécone
merci pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice procacia vous évoquez à raison
ce rapport publié le mois dernier par le
Sénat dont vous êtes l'auteur et qui se
termine par ces deux phrases disons que
effectivement la gestion de la
chlordécone entre 1973 et 1993 aux
Antilles et surtout ses conséquences
depuis doivent nous servir de boussole
ou de guide vous conviendrez que
quelques semaines seulement après la
publication de ce rapport et de cette
conclusion nous n'ayons pas forcément pu
tirer je le dis avec beaucoup d'humilité
toutes les conclusions d'un certain
nombre de pollution qui pour certaines
persistent alors même que les produits
ont été interdits dans votre rapport
vous pointez l'impact sur la santé vous
évoquez aussi les dégâts du manque de
transparence et la nécessité de la
prévention et de l'anticipation
en termes de transparence depuis un peu
plus de deux ans un site internet
méconnu de la plupart de nos concitoyens
gérés par le ministère de la transition
écologique infosol recense toutes les
pollutions existantes et il est mis à
jour de manière régulière
les SIS qui sont adossés au parcelles
qui sont des documents qui permettent à
des propriétaires qui acquièrent une
propriété de pouvoir mesurer toutes les
pollutions recensées sur leur site sont
aussi un des leviers la Commission
européenne en ce moment même avec le
soutien de la France prépare une
résolution sur la santé des sols qui va
se pencher sur le sujet puis nous avons
rendez-vous dans quelques jours avec un
cas pratique
les polluants éternels les péfaces
vendredi je rendrai public le rapport
commandé à l'IGD qui fait le point sur
la réalité de cette pollution par les
perflux
dans le fait qu'ils sont extrêmement
persistants
un plan d'action dévoilé en janvier par
mon ministère a mis l'accent sur la
nécessité de connaître de recenser
d'améliorer les informations de mesurer
les endroits où il y a potentiellement
des problématiques pour la santé et là
aussi une action européenne sur ce sujet
est en préparation avec d'autres pays
parce qu'on mesure les limites qu'il y a
à prendre des décisions dans un seul
pays si les molécules franchissent nos
frontières au travers des produits
agricoles ou industriels qui permettent
de les amener merci pour votre question
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'ai lu votre
plan d'action sur les péfaces mais c'est
plus du préventif que du curatif or dans
le défaut de la couleur déconne on n'a
pas financé les recherches vous parlez
de 93 moi je parle de tous les plans
depuis 2005 2006 et ce n'est que
maintenant en 2023 qu'il y a vraiment
des efforts de recherche vous parlez
d'infossol je dirais que dans le rapport
nous dénonçons le fait que justement aux
Antilles toutes les toutes les terres
cultivables n'ont pas été analysés donc
aller sur un site qui ne recense pas
tout n'est pas non plus forcément
efficace donc je dis il faut comme vous
l'avez rappelé dans la conclusion il
faut une vision d'ensemble et pour
l'avenir
merci
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres merci nous avons
terminé avec les questions au
Gouvernement nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 3
mai 2023 à 15h je vais suspendre la
séance ce sera reprise à 16h30 pour le
débat d'actualité sur le thème impact
économique sociale et politique de
l'intelligence artificielle générative
la séance est suspendue